his name is Gary Vaynerchuk let's go
back a little bit he grew up in the wine
business I think we have a photo of him
when he was a kid kind of his family was
all about wine right and it wasn't a
wino or anything he just you know he
drank he drink responsibly yeah but as
he got older he was looking for ways to
promote the family business and he got
computer savvy
and what did he do he took to YouTube
and various social media to get the word
out in a very creative way about his
family's wine business in Springfield
New Jersey we have now been following
him and we're now vayniacs this morning
so nice to have you here you know
everybody is on social media we tweet we
Facebook Instagram but maybe we don't
use it in the right way to help our
business yeah I mean listen uh most
people don't use it for business let's
start there most people use it to share
their baby pictures or make jokes or
like not work for a few minutes right
even escape but for the people that are
using it for business you know I think
they need to understand there's a real
strategy I don't love social media for
any other reason than it sells stuff you
know I'm a businessman
I sold lemonade when I was five and
baseball cards when I was twelve right
so I'm not in this for the kicks and
giggles I'm in this because one day I
want to buy the New York Jets well your
clips that's a that's a great ambition
your eclipse though did inspire a lot of
giggles but maybe it sold a lot of wine
to take a look at this then we'll talk
about it watch please I always talk
about I always talk about it the terroir
the dirt the soil that's how you really
get in this is fine New Jersey wine
right here that's right you gotta eat
the dirt because that's how you really
get in there and that's how you know
where it's coming from
it's imperative and now some 99 crystal
baby this is not a Somali a that I'm
familiar with yes that was really wild
and unique and it you became a sensation
and your business took off yeah I mean
listen my business took off because I
started winelibrary.com in 1996 right so
when everybody thought nobody would ever
have a website or put credit cards into
a computer I did when YouTube came out
in 2006 and everybody thought it was a
silly thing for cat videos I saw
something else and my big thing with
wine and why you saw what you saw was do
you guys have friends or are you guys
into wine yeah of course so as you may
know once somebody gets a little bit of
wine knowledge they become a jerk-off I
was passionate about talking to people
about wine instead of down to them and
so that's what it's all about and social
media what Twitter Facebook Pinterest
now vine allows me to do is tell stories
just like this platform on television
it's about telling stories about your
videos they're very scrappy they're not
like really overproduced or anything
that's our Jersey I love it
it could be Jersey Brooklyn whatever its
to the people it's just simple and
direct and at the end of the day this
was a story that I wanted to tell but
what really helped was engagement you
know I was looking at your accounts I
look at other people's accounts people
are pushing stuff out you know the
people that are watching this show right
now they will get their feeds and
they'll see news from you but they want
to interact they want to say hello they
want somebody to talk back to them
everybody's thinking about content but
it's about context Gary let me ask yes
but by the way your social media skills
eventually became bigger than the wine
business
I mean you are kind of fully engaged now
you're a social media expert second
career my brother AJ and I started a
social media agency four years ago we
have a 230 person firm here in the city
it's going extremely well who is some of
your clients the Brooklyn Nets GE del
Monte foods PepsiCo Green Mountain
Coffee major fortune 500 brands give us
around a bad idea what you charge a
month
around about halfway home to six figures
halfway home to six figures fifty grand
very good okay and your your main
message to them is what I mean what I
want to humanize brands brands are
always pushing I know the people that
are watching right now that's why I'm
looking at them and I know you're not
supposed to look at the camera you don't
want more people pushing crap down your
throat on your feed you want to have
value you want to get your answer to
your question you want to have a little
fun I want to humanize these brands
instead of them just pushing and selling
I'm writing a new book it's called jab
jab jab right hook combine it manually
jab jab right hook give give give ask
and if you look at most Twitter and
Facebook feeds it's push push push push
push
so Twitter yeah what are we doing wrong
it's not that what you're doing wrong
but you're missing out on opportunities
I look at your tweets there's people
that are responding you can just say
hello a wink from you you're a legend in
this city right let's go it's called
what it is somebody at home right now
who's watching right now if they said
that's great you're wearing a beautiful
dress today if you just said thank you
to them that means something here's what
I think I think you need to give effort
I think when you care about the end
consumer good things happen I do think
that when you're walking out of here for
two minutes you take out your phone and
you say hi to two people that those two
people are more likely to tune in more
often because there's a bigger emotional
connection well so there's also older
promise there's over low here it's nice
you mentioned push push push push push
people are pushing things all the time
on us Pinterest tumblr all those other
sites you mentioned I mean is there any
fatigue out there of course there is but
there's fatigue to everything there's
fatigue to commercials there's fatigue
the banner ads there's fatigue to email
here's what it comes down to there's a
lot of morning shows why do people tune
into this one because you're good it
comes down to quality plenty people
gonna push if you push good stuff you
win you said before we coming on the air
that what the videos were good you're
right that's why it worked well a lot of
folks are pushing stuff that always
so-so and there's a lot of crap on TV
too fair enough
Gary would you watch it 7:15
there yes Gary it's so great to somebody
I think we're gonna bring a little wine
for us next time let's do it fourth of
July is coming around we'll do some pics
really yeah we have to wait a bit yes
roughly roughly when are you gonna buy
the Jets when's that gonna happen I'm 38
I'm hoping to pin it down by 58 so maybe
I think you have a better shot at the
Mets than the Jess
my brother-in-law Alex would be thrilled
if I pulled that off all right Gary I
think it's gonna happen yeah we knew
it'd win thank you guys so much
Gary thank you